xem xong đi vây giờ bài rạm này cái em trung lớp, bật li của
in trên cái sơ nó là thế bè này là gì hứt thì kết
thì mà thật ra rất đừng rạm
cái em làm như sao?
lộ dịch truyền thì ta chỉ cần xác mình nửa vào đi vưới thôi
nhưng mình nửa nửa sức phát
nhất ảnh nhời này
nhưng vẫn lộ dịch truyền là profund giát bé được xa tệ
nếp này nó ngốc b θ để richtig đ honored
như vậy hay s 대해서 nộ الطà sẽ ng sums đọc dịch truyền
ở 8 chứng ả nhất
Được chào, bây giờ mình sẽ nử tính lộ dịch truyền là đi tính lộ ra ai của cái cạnh
Ad được lộ ra ai cạnh, Ad được. Vậy thế, không?
Thế không? Thế không? Thế không? Thế không? Cái này mà, cái này nữa?
Vậy cạnh này sẽ mạnh năm. Yêu vậy, hay được. Ad đi, bằng 5 kỳ đo壓.
Cái ăn là hôm trước thế nói cho cái chứa đo壓 thì quán người bằng tập cất hoạn thằng mà vật đi,
bằng wrench, bằng trā màu cô lại này a bằng xấu kỳ đúng avec puff đúng không,
mình nước ph bik lói m sûr cái đúng tôi Soon Anders ởies để ở d mówią Watchb坐,
bằng này ATSEx dabei, a nữa gusta gì? Cái này sẽ đồ một được images của mình хоть đang thế MJ